je suis d'accord sur ce portrait d'un
financière surtout que monsieur biya a
été très honnête
est-ce que je peux parler un médecin
j'ai lu tous vos livres
je les aime chez moi sur tous vos livres
sur le vietnam
je pense qu'en effet vous avez été très
marqué par la chine du passé marqué
comme maudite par cette horreur marqué
par le fait que vous viviez une vie a
complètement schizophrène ce qu'un
enfant supporte très mal à l'enfant
supporte très mal en effet de voir ses
parents administrés et être faire partie
de cette horreur quand lui même parce
qu'un enfant un sens de la justice il
réprouve
moi j'ai souffert terriblement un enfant
dans la vieille chine de voir les
mendiants mourir je les ramasse est de
voir les horreurs qui étaient autour de
moi de voir les gens mourir de faim mais
je crois que si vous vous m'excuserez
pour le dire je le dis un médecin
pédiatre que certains enfants restent
marquées toute leur vie et ne peuvent
pas se détacher de ses souvenirs il s'y
attache peut-être un peu trop fort cela
est arrivé non seulement à vous monsieur
beaux draps c'est peut-être arriver
aussi même des chinois quand la
révolution est arrivée des bourgeois
comme moi ont certainement dû penser à
une autre sorte de chine une chine où
nous qu'ils étaient seulement les 1% de
la population qui avions tous nous
devions penser pour une fois aux 99 %
qui n'avait rien qu'ils n'avaient aucune
liberté excepté la liberté de mourir de
faim on parle de coercition en chine
aujourd'hui mais la plus grande des
coéditions bien sûr c'est la famille
quand vous parlez des ombres dans le
travail collectif en 1956 moi je suis
retourné en chine en 1955 et 1956 et
j'ai en effet trouvé comme vous que mes
souvenirs de la vieille chine des
souvenirs auquel on est attaché par ses
racines
infantile d'enfants que ça faisait mal
mais d'un autre côté j'ai vu pour une
fois les gens manger à leur faim
j'ai vu que les enfants ne mourrait plus
nous avions 250 enfants pour 1000 qui
mouraient dans la première année de leur
vie
maintenant ils vivaient tous j'ai vu la
véritable délivrance d'un peuple qui est
la délivrance des grandes coercition la
faim la misère et l'ignorance
vous parlez des ombres mais si vous
retournez en chine aujourd'hui en 1975
et c'est pour ça que j'ai tant attendu
pour écrire ses livres j'ai attendu
jusqu'à ce que j'étais sûr si vous
retournez aujourd'hui peut-être que vous
trouveriez que la beauté et la couleur
et l'art qui sont tous revenus
mona lisa intervenir je ne pense pas que
monsieur wada aurait tellement les
difficultés qu il le dit pour une chose
parce que le président mao a dit mais il
faut avoir des gens de toutes sortes
comme il l'a dit il faut que tout le
monde s'exprime je suis sûr que si
monsieur paul boudart disent eh bien
franchement bain peut-être que je
devrais revoir ses idées qui après tout
sont fondées dans cette horreur du passé
mais cette horreur qui était fascinante
aussi qui avait sa fascination parce que
j'étais un enfant de trois quatre cinq
ans parce que mon âme à saint-servan
tête et chinoises parce que mon mac ou
mahfouz veut dire le mot nome qui
s'occupe du cheval était chinois parce
que j'avais des serviteurs et des
domestiques parce que j'étais comme un
petit roi dans cette chine du passé où
il y avait vraiment tant d'horreurs et
je les ai écrites aux six mois comme
vous oui eh bien je dis que si vous
disiez ça je ne crois pas je crois que
si vous alliez vraiment avec l'intention
de vraiment voir ce qui a été fait pour
le peuple chinois et non pas seulement
pour cette petite poignée de gens que
vous connaissez ou que vous pensiez
quand
m peut-être que vous étés changerait et
moi